all right good morning thanks for coming
welcome to the session on refactoring to
functional style my name is Venkat
Subramanyam we're going to talk about
taking a few examples and then looking
at the examples in imperative style of
programming and then we'll refactor it
to functional style I'll probably spend
about 5 minutes or so just talking about
functional style of programming then we
will step into maybe about five or six
different examples and take a look at
the code and then refactor it we have to
use some language for the exercise I'll
be using Java here but pretty much you
can use any language you want to as long
as you can find a VI or a function that
can get the work done but more important
it's really thinking about the approach
how do we really approach a functional
style of programming best time to ask
questions or make comments is when you
have it if you do have a question or
comment please draw my attention and
then start speaking up I'll be more than
happy to listen to you so let's get
started well first of all I want to talk
a little about functional style of
programming but unfortunately though
predominantly in over industry we have
spent a several decades programming in
the imperative style of programming so
let's talk a little bit about imperative
style so what in the world is really
imperative style of programming well it
really comes down to you tell what to do
and also you spend the time telling also
how to do it so this is one of the
biggest challenges with imperative style
of programming is you have to spend a
lot of time telling not only what you
want to do but you also have to spend
time telling how to do it let's talk
about this with a little example real
quick let's say we are interested in
finding the name R in upper case of a
first person older than 30 in the given
list of names right here how would we do
this well remember the result we want is
the name of somebody so as a result we
will start with string name but what do
we do initially we will have to set it
to null that's a very first smell isn't
it I see a few people laughing already
null is a smell it doesn't really get as
excited then what do we do then we say
purse and of course in this case we're
gonna get a particular person from this
function called create people and then
what we do after that we say if person
dot get age is greater than 30 because
that's what we really want then what do
we do we say name
equal to and then person dot get named R
to uppercase and then we convert it to
an uppercase and then of course I would
say if name is not equal to null this is
adding insult to injury isn't it and
then you have to come here and say the
name and of course if the value was not
present you're going to say in this case
no one found well unfortunately though
you will quickly observe this and say
I'm wrong in this code because I forgot
to put a break right here that is our
responsibility isn't it if you don't put
a break in the best case you will get a
slower performance in the worst case
we'll get a wrong result so as a result
it's it's up to you to really do this of
course when I run this code it gives you
the result of Paulo I'm not gonna ask
you if anyone here has written the code
like this because everyone has but I'm
gonna ask you more important question
how do you feel when you write code like
this I'll tell you how you feel you feel
really dirty because when you go home
when children come running towards you
said don't touch me I gotta go shower
first right that's what we feel when we
write code like this every day
this is imperative style of programming
you tell what to do and you also tell
how to do it that's a lot of work as you
can see in this particular example but
we're gonna trade that to water called
higher-order functions so what in the
world is a higher-order function well
normally I'll say a normal function I
don't even know if that's the right word
is where we are going to be may pass
object to a function so we do this all
the time we may create object in a
function so we do that also and then
finally we may return object from a
function so this is basically what we do
normally with functions is we pass
objects we create objects we return
objects but on the other hand we can
trade that to water called higher-order
functions and in the higher-order
functions what we really do is we pass
functions two functions we may create
function within a function and we may
return a function from a function so
this gives a nice way for us do not just
work with objects but also use
functional decomposition as well in
addition to object decomposition so
becomes a really nice way to pass
functions around let's see how that's
gonna feel in just a minute but one of
the other things about function seller
programming is we favor immutability if
you notice over here we create a
variable called name and we are mutating
that variable and then we keep mutating
variables over and over and over well
what happens when you mutate variables a
it becomes really hard to reason the
code when you mutate variables it
becomes incredibly hard to parallelize
the code as well errors creep in when we
start doing very many mutations on the
other hand we could write this in a
functional style but it really comes
down to what's called the Declaration
style of programming now I'll talk about
what's the relationship in just a minute
but declaration style is essentially
where you tell what and not how so this
is one of the beautiful things about
declaration style is you tell what to do
and not how to do it but of course we
are talking about functional style here
so what in the world then is functional
style and to me this is what exciting
about functional style is functional
style is actually declarative plus the
use of higher-order functions so this is
the relationship between the two styles
of programming is there a functional
style of programming ease declarative
and plus we use higher-order functions
this is one of the reasons why
functional style really shines is
because it's actually declarative that's
where the expressive nature of the code
really comes in so in this case we're
gonna use lambda expressions obviously
for higher-order functions but this
leads to a beautiful thing called a
collection pipeline or a functional
composition let's take a look at what
that really means in this example so I'm
gonna get back to this little example
that we have with us and what I'm going
to do here is our output let's start
with the create people and then we'll
call a stream this is purely a Java
issue but in the case of other languages
like C sharp you can directly do this on
a list if you will because of extension
methods and then of course you can take
the stream and I'm gonna say filter and
I'll say that given a person I want to
get a person dot get age over here is
greater than 30 then I perform a map
operation to get the name
of the person I perform a map again to
get the string upper to upper case and
then finally I'll say fine first and if
the person doesn't exist I would say
well I'll simply say no one found and
this gives us an ability to get the real
value our substitute value if the value
were not really found well notice the
flow of the code how expressive the code
really is now here's a challenge I would
pose to you take an imperative code and
show it to a programmer but sit in front
of them and watch their eyeball movement
and when they look at the imperative
code that eyeball movement is going to
be like this isn't it and then it's
gonna do this that's called the point of
confusion right on the other hand if you
look at this one notice how beautifully
it flows through a single pass through
and you're able to get it and that's one
of the beautiful things about functional
style is you're able to read the code in
one pass the code begins to read like
the problem statement that becomes a lot
more easier to follow as well but of
course the question is okay this is
awesome this code is cute I love it but
I have this theory and the theory I have
is cuteness cuteness
well cuteness is not sustainable so this
is the truth of human beings as ended
you know when you a baby is born we say
how cute when the baby is two years old
we don't like the baby anymore right
talking too much so cuteness is not
sustainable this code is really cute but
at the end of the day we want
performance and so what about efficiency
well if you look at languages like Ruby
or Python or JavaScript unfortunately
those languages will perform all the
computations do all the work and discard
most of the work and take the very first
result
what a waste in performance well
thankfully that's not the way functional
programming should work and in this case
just to prove the point I go to the
person class and in the person class I
put a print statement in the get age
method now if I go back to the
imperative style code for a second we
know imperative code is usually really
performant when I run the code you will
notice it evaluated Sarah Sarah Bob
but it never touched anybody after Paulo
because we use the break statement on
line 25 and the break saves the day for
us it doesn't waste performance because
once it finds the result it builds out
well that is the imperative style code
but the question is what about the
functional style code what is it going
to do well thankfully that's where the
laziness of evaluation really comes in
and laziness is fundamentally very
important for functional programming
because without laziness we're gonna
create cute code which is not going to
really perform very well so when I run
this code the functional code notice it
did not behave any different internally
it did not touch anyone
after Paulo because of lazy evaluation
it knows to bail out at the right point
and not do any extra work than is
necessary so that gives us an idea about
how efficiency is important and at the
same time we get efficiency with
functional style as well what's really
cool about these ideas is that we don't
have to be programming in an esoteric
language to be able to do this
mainstream languages like Java and
c-sharp supported today and as a result
we can benefit from these ideas in
almost any language we program every
single day clearly we can use those
other beautiful languages as well but we
have the freedom to choose if you will
so to understand this further let's take
some exercises and play with it real
quick so the first exercise I want to
start with here is going to take us from
imperative style to decorative and a
functional style of code
well this code be going to look at is
fairly noisy as you can see right here I
got a function called East Prime when I
run the code notice it tells us one is
not prime but two and three are but four
is not but five years and six is not but
seven is okay so it works but look at
the code real quick what are we doing in
this code notice first of all we create
a variable called divisible now honestly
when you're writing code you're not
gonna call it divisible you're gonna
call it temp or T because that's how you
tell the code you don't deserve to live
that's how we communicate our you know
dislike of the code we are writing these
car these are called garbage variables
garbage variables are variables that are
introduced as part of the solution
they're not required as part of the
problem really then we say once we set
the divisible equal to false we loop
through one value at a time and then we
are checking if a value divides the
given number if it does we say divisible
is true and we break out of the loop and
then at this point of course we check if
it's not divisible and perform the
action while this code is working let's
think about how we can implement this in
a better way if you will so I'm going to
bring in the necessary package right
here but let's put this in English what
are we really trying to do so given a
range of numbers let's say to do number
minus 1 well then no number in the range
divides the given number the number
that's been given isn't it well that's a
very first thing I tend to do is I try
to put the words in in English or
whatever language you're comfortable
natural language once you write that as
a phrase it's a question of converting
that to code that's a really nice
transition a lot of times when people
struggle to write functional code one
thing I realize is I know it's a little
hard for us but remember the days when
we started programming today you're not
probably using flowchart but you
probably did write flowcharts in the
beginning and honestly even today if I'm
doing something extremely complex and
I'm not able to hold it in my head I'll
take a napkin and scribble a few things
on it and then I would sneeze on it and
throw it away but the point really is we
try to really write things down when
things are really hard or complex well
thinking functionally is hard and
complex for a lot of us be included so I
try to not normally put it in phrases
like this given a range of numbers then
from 2 to number minus 1 no number in
the range divides the given number well
then once I do that it becomes really
easy what I'm gonna do then is to simply
say return number is greater than 1 and
in the stream dart range notice the word
range right there becomes range over
here and I said no number in the range
so that becomes an unmatched function
index number Mart I is equal to zero so
as a result right now we are taking that
a phrase in English and we are simply
converting it to code pretty much a
declarative style of code right there so
when we run this code of course it
produces the same result but we simply
formulated the problem in a series of
steps to follow in terms of the actions
to perform that trends transformations
to do and then we are translating that
to code as you can see right here so
what does a benefit this code really
offers well first of all notice that
code is really concise the code is very
highly expressive you're not trying to
get into the nuts and bolts and looking
at how things actually work the instead
you are simply focusing on the fact that
given a range of numbers tell me none
matches this rule of divisibility so
that the code becomes a lot more easier
to express easier to read as well that
is one of the biggest benefits you get
out of this is a code that is easier to
understand easier to work with easier to
read as well from that point of view
I'll make one observation that I'm
beginning to realize more and more when
it comes to imperative style of
programming we have decades of
experience writing this code so I'm
gonna say easier to write really hard to
read so when you write an imperative
code you're able to write it the
programmer always writes it but everyone
who comes after that to read it were
those people they're not called
programmers they're called victims
because you're trying to really
understand this code so it's really hard
to read and also hard to maintain on the
other hand if you really think about it
when it comes to the function of style
of programming because of our lack of
experience more than anything else we
don't really have an ability to write
this code really easily so I'm gonna say
hard to write really in this case easy
to read and also easy to maintain and
also of course moving forward you could
say easy to parallel eyes as well so
this is one of the things as I'm gonna
say it is
hard to write in the context of saying
we just don't have experience doing it
and that's what makes it really hard to
write not because it's fundamentally
hard it's because of lack of her
experience we're not as familiar with it
and and on the other hand this is easier
to write because we spent decades doing
it so it's natural for us to write it
but it's really hard for us to read it
later on and that's a balance we have to
strike but remember the code is written
once but it is read thousands of times
so we need to optimize for reading not
optimized for writing that's one of the
key things to really keep in mind is
where we are really heading with this so
having talked about this let's move a
little forward so in this case of course
the code is less noisy no garbage
variables of course we are using
higher-order functions to the none match
function we passed another function
which is a lambda expression let's take
the next example right here again we'll
go from imperative functional style of
coding in this example I have a search
word called localhost and looking for
the word in the EDC host file and if you
are used to Java you know how terrible
this code really is because if you
notice over here I had to read the line
put into a variable and check if it is
not equal to null I always tell people
never show code like this to children
because they will never then want to
become programmers right my children
that's what they did I used to put them
on my lap when I coded them terrible
idea I tell parents these days never do
this with children and and they were
fine they were playing with the keyboard
until they got a little bit bigger and
one day they looked at my code and said
dad this is what you do for a living and
that's what's not really fun at all so
the point really is you don't want to be
really be tortured by code like this
it's very inhumane well the good news is
we don't have to struggle this hard we
can use library of functions again so in
this case I'm gonna say Java dart n io
dart file well how am I gonna in a
recover from this code well the beauty
of this is this is working way too hard
I'm gonna comment out all of that code
and all I'm gonna do is simply say a
longer count is equal to because after
all I'm looking for the count and in
this case I'll say file start
in this case aligns and Pat's dog yet
and the file if I am interested in the
horse file then I say filter right here
and I'm given a line I want the line
that contains which is exactly what we
did right here so grab that essential
part right here contains that and then
dot count and it gives us the same
result as the other one and the point
really is we can eliminate all that
extra word and we can simply create a
stream of data in this case the stream
of data coming from a file rather than
coming from a collection and then we are
iterating through it much like in the
functional style and then we are
filtering out what we really are
interested in and then we got the count
out of that and that becomes a lot more
easier to work with so talking about
this we don't have any explicit
mutability in this code that is one of
the beautiful things about functional
style of code as functional style code
is very humane no variable is tortured
in the making of the results we're not
going to mutate variables over and over
and of course in this case we use a
stream of data and applied the operation
like filtering to achieve that well
where we can really benefit from this is
again I would emphasize the real benefit
comes from the declarative style not
just from the higher-order functions so
always I keep thinking of declarative
style when it comes to programming
because thinking about what to do and
avoiding the how to do it so this next
example will illustrate this really well
because you can look at how hard this
code is to write so let's see what this
code is doing
I got a collection of values called
scores a dictionary and c-sharp very
similar idea so here is a map in Java
which is like a dictionary in c-sharp
and all I'm doing here is collecting
creating a map over here of scores and
have Jack Jill tom Darla's Nick and
Nancy with different score values some
names have same score some names have
different score but what i'm doing here
is group by score so when i run the code
notice it gives me levin as the score
and Tom and then
have leaven as the score 12 is under the
score only jak has it 15 is another
score but Darla Nick and Jill have it so
I'm kind of inverting this map in other
words I want to group them based on the
score values and the names of the people
who have that score but how am I doing
this this can be a really nice exercise
when you want to really you know see how
people code look at the the pathetic
code here we are first creating a map of
integer as the key and a list of strings
as the value type and then of course we
look through the key set in the
collection we take one name at a time
then what do we do we first ask if that
name exists as a key if that absorb we
get the score for that name from the
original collection then we go ask
whether that score appears as a key
within the collection if it does that's
great if it doesn't we create a new
collection and then once we create a new
collection or get the collection we add
the element to the collection and then
we put it back so this is an extremely
low level code as you can see you
control every single step of your way
through this that's a lot of burden we
carry as programmers in this case so
this is like you know telling a
programmer tie a Phi kilo weight on your
wrist and start coding how would you
feel if you code for entire day with a 5
kilo weight on your wrist well we've
been carrying that 5 kilo weight that's
called imperative style of programming
and that's what we've been doing all
this time when you run this code it
produces the result but let's see how we
can do this a lot better so what I'm
gonna do here again is look for things
that can make our life a lot easier well
the first thing I'm gonna bring in is a
little bit of a helper here and one of
the challenges when it comes to
programming in these languages is not
learning a syntax but learning a
thinking process but also start looking
for methods that you can use in the
library
and that has been one of the challenges
is to keep the eyes open and say look
this method is really powerful I can
benefit from this rather than doing all
the work at the lower level by myself so
in this case return and I'm gonna start
with the given collection which is the
scores collection so I'm gonna see a
score start and we ask for the key set
because that's what this Court did get
the key set then I'm asking for a stream
on it and once I do I'm gonna start
collecting but in this case I'm gonna
say grouping by and what am I really
grouping by well given a score I want to
get the score well in this case of
course I'm getting the name isn't it
so given the name I'm gonna get the
score start get for the name and I'm
asking you to get me thus the perform
the grouping but perform the grouping
based on the name but get the score from
the name so in other words group based
on the score let's think about what this
one powerful line really means this is
extremely concise code there's a lot of
stuff going on in it so it's a bigger
learning curve it's kind of like
operating a crane versus digging the
ground using you know tools by hand well
obviously to dig with the hand doesn't
require a whole lot of skill but it's a
lot of labour and sweating but you won't
let anybody to get down that crane some
kind of education and learning is needed
but the person sitting on the crane can
press the button and let the machine do
the work the get the grouping by method
is like the crane but you got to know
what button to press really but what is
grouping by really doing well
essentially what this code is doing is
it literally creates a bucket and once
it creates a bucket it says if a bucket
doesn't exist for a particular score I'm
gonna create a new bucket if the bucket
exists I'm gonna fetch the element that
is there already and then add the
element back to it after appending so it
takes care of all the work that we have
to do by using this declaration style of
approach
so more than functional style here it is
the decorative
within the functional style that's
really shining at this point now this is
more about job and more than anything
else in the next one but I know that
c-sharp also has very much facilities
like that where you can simply go back
to this and say I want to simply call
the get method and you can make the code
a little bit more concise and expressive
as well so that is an example of how you
can rewrite the code to avoid a lot of
work that you otherwise have to do so
that gives you an idea about how you can
minimize all that extra effort in
writing this code in the in this
particular case so what did we achieve
by doing this well it's very highly
expressive but like I said what really
shines here is the declarative nature of
functional style but we have to really
know what kind of functions we have to
use and this is one of the challenges of
functional style of programming is not
everything is going to fit into a filter
map and reduce we have to look for other
methods in the gender available in the
libraries and the packages we are using
and and always keep an eye for this
declaration of nature where you can tell
what to do rather than having to get
immersed into how to do these things
well the next example I'm going to show
you here is something I got as a email
from somebody asking hey I've seen your
talks before but here's a problem and I
can't quite figure out how to implement
it so I thought I will use this from
somebody who actually sent a problem
very similar to this one and it really
illustrates the point but before I talk
about it I want to go back and talk
about something a little bit else
because it really helps to hone in on
the idea of some of the functional you
know programming methods we normally use
so to understand this let's talk about a
few methods we normally use we normally
use a filter well in the case of C sharp
things like select and wear are very
much equivalent to this in F sharp you
use the word filter in C sharp you quite
don't but the concepts are really the
same across the languages so we
typically use a filter and we use a map
things like for example select and we're
in C sharp or filter and map in in F
sharp and in Java and other languages as
well but one confusion about
times developers have is you know when
when do I use filter versus maybe when
do I use a flat map so I want to spend a
few minutes really identifying when I
would probably use a flat map because
looking at it this way has truly helped
me in my understanding so to understand
this I'm gonna take a silly example and
work with it
let's take a list of numbers in this
case just let's let's say these numbers
1 2 3 4 a minute I'm gonna write a silly
method right here in double it and the
double it method takes a number and all
it's going to do is return number times
2 so that's pretty you know it's easy to
see what it's doing but I'm gonna write
one more method as well and in this case
I will write it as let's call this as
before-and-after pictures which is
pretty silly but the straights the point
I'm gonna return in this case a new
collection an array in this case I'll
say number plus 1 and number minus 1 has
two different values
so given this collection of values what
do they want to do well if I wanted to
really double each of the values in the
collection what would I do
I would say number start and then I
would say map right here and given an
element in the collection I would say
double it of the element and then of
course I'd say for each and I will print
it out system.out.println and I will
just print it out so when it run this
code notice it reduced the values 2 4 &
6 well that's a clearly a nice little
example of using map function
nothing really confusing over there but
on the other hand let's go ahead and say
numbers start stream but in this case
I'm gonna perform a map operation but
I'm gonna say before and after E and
then I'm gonna say for each system dot
out print line well there's a bit of a
problem right now with this code the
reason why this is a problem is we're
using the map function here as much as
in the previous case but when you look
at the output unfortunately look at how
nasty that 1s
it gives you an array or yeah it gives
you a collection of arrays or array for
each element most likely not what you
really wanted let's step back and look
at this a little bit different before we
go any further look at the function
double it for one second what can we say
about double it double it is a one to
one one to one function so what does
that really mean a one to one function
means given one object it returns back
one object to you on the other hand look
at the before and after a function is a
one-to-many function so in this case
what the before-and-after does is given
one value it returns multiple values so
one of the things I normally do is I
look at the function I'm using and ask
the question is it a one-to-one function
R is it a one-to-many function well
typically speaking here's a way to think
about it so if the function is
one-to-one well then use map if the
function is one too many
well if it's one too many then what
should we use then use we'll come back
to that in just a minute
well we'll take a detour and come back
to this in just a minute
let's switch really quickly to Ruby here
only because it's a little bit easier
for me to show this in Ruby so let's
take a look at a list is equal to and
I'm gonna say 1 2 3 4 5 & 6
well I'm asking for list start count and
clearly you can see the list has six
elements no confusion about it on the
other hand if I go back to this code and
I put a little square bracket right
there now what does the list really
contain it contains a single element 1 a
single element 2 but it contains a
collection which which internally
contains 3 4 & 5 and then a single
element when I ask for the count nor the
value right now is a 4 because the list
is
contains four elements not six elements
but what I can do though is I can ask
for list art flatten and then I can ask
for account
notice when I flatten it it becomes a
value of six so what is flat and really
do the flatten actually so if I say
something like Lister 2 equal to list
one dot flatten listed to really is
going to be the following is equal to
one two three four five and six so in
other words it flattens the list so when
a list contains a collection of
collections the flagon will just flatten
it out and give you one collection with
only those elements directly not a
collection of collection well so what
are we really after here well remember
if we use a map with a one-to-many
function or what are we really getting
well here's the beauty if you take a
collection I'm using a word very loosely
here instead of using the word stream if
it's a collection of tea dot map let's
call it as f1 where function f1 one
function one to one then the result of
this is a collection of are where the
return type of the function is a Type R
unfortunately if you say collection of
tea dot map function want to end on it
the result of this unfortunately is a
collection of collection of are maybe
not what you really wanted so what if
you really want to get a collection
right so in other words you're saying
give it a collection of tea
I want as pass a one to n function but
what I want as a result is a collection
of are not a collection of collection of
our hello how would you do that well
here's a very easy way to do it you can
perform a collection of tea dot map f1 n
dot flatten and then you can perform
that to get a collection of our isn't it
so in other words what you want to do
you want to perform the map operation
and then you want to perform a
flattening operation on it well instead
of doing as a two-step process why not
combine them so what you really want it
is a function called map flat now I want
to pose a challenge on you don't do this
too much but try this maybe when you're
alone at home and try saying this try
saying the word mat flat this hurts the
jaw really bad you couldn't try it this
is so awkward mat flat the the mouth
doesn't move properly humans were not
created to say words like that and
imagine if they had created a map flat
function 300 years later humans will be
structurally different the descendants
of programmers is in there so this is so
they will know these people were born to
programmers because they said Matt flat
and that did not go well at all I'm so
thankful to them forever they called it
flat math how easy that is to say so
this was purely called as a flat map
because mat flat doesn't try this at
home you will know the pain I'm talking
about right that is so awkward to say it
so thank goodness they call it flat map
so a combination of flat map performs a
masters and then performs a flattening
after that it's a reverse order to save
the human jaw so the point really is
that you're gonna take the map operation
and then you're gonna flatten it after
that well now that we talked about how
this works let's go ahead and give it a
try so I'm gonna take this code right
here and what I'm gonna do is to scale
it's called flat map and of course in
this case I'm going to simply say stream
dart off this is again more specific to
Java but the idea remains the same and
I'm going to bring this in into a stream
and as a result notice when I run this
code this is applying the flat map
operation where it performs that
transformation or mapping first and then
it flattens it out to get the results
after that and so we can see the result
over here is 0 2 1 3 & 2 for which
the values we are expecting not that
silly array that it was returning inside
of that so that gives us an idea about
how this actually works so this becomes
a really nice way to implement it well
having done this now let's go back to
the problem I really wanted to work with
which is the problem that this gentleman
sent me to say how do you really solve
this problem so when he sent me the
question he had been exposed to filter
and map and reduce and he had really
trouble connecting to the idea because
this problem was a little bit more
intense and when I looked at the problem
I said I see the problem here the issue
is not with mapping it's a one-to-many
function and so that's why we need to
really use a flat map operation so we're
gonna use functional composition clearly
but we're gonna engage into a few other
computations as well let's take a look
at the code before we talk about the
solution well this is going to use the
solution of the Euclid's algorithm to
provide four values of a B and C which
satisfy this particular equation the
values of a B and C where a square plus
B square is equal to C square so when
you run this code I'm asking for 10
different values in here notice three
four five and six eight ten and so on so
these are the ten values for combination
of a B and C but of course you could
also ask for 15 values if you really
want to do and that's going to be 15
different values but the point really in
this case is how do we find it well you
puts algorithm says given a value of m
and n we can find out the a B and C for
those values by using these this formula
so it's it says you know given this M
and n here you go here's a value of a B
and C well that's great but how do we
use this to find ten values or fifteen
values and so on so if you look at the
code notice what it does it first
creates an array list or a list of
Triple A triples once it creates a list
of triples it says count is equal to one
I want that many number of values so we
start with M going from 2 to infinity
literally and then n goes from 1 but 1
less than M and then of course we go
ahead and call the get triple for that
value of M and N in the loop and we add
it to the triples collection then we
increment the count then we say if the
count is greater than number of values
perform a break but unfortunately look
at this beautiful code we have to do
this one more time this Court deserves
framing on the wall isn't that to say
this is of the life of a programmer is
where we have to break out of the loop
once and again twice right so this is
really not very pleasant code again but
that's because we have to break out of
the inner loop but we also have to break
out of the outer loop as well it's not
that much code but it's not that
intuitive as well so let's go ahead and
run this again that's the output we got
from this code but what am I going to do
to replace this code with a functional
style well first of all couple of things
to really think about notice the for
loop that is here well the for loop what
is the for loop do again put it into
words
so iterate over the range from 2 to
infinity right so it is unbounded
iteration that's what it is on the other
hand what does this do
iterate in this case over the range 1 to
M minus 1
so this is again an iteration that you
are dealing with
but there's another observation you need
to make in this code only look at the
inner loop for a minute what does the
inner loop really do the inner loop goes
from n equal to 1 to M minus 1 but the
result of the inner loop is it generates
a collection of these values that are
returned by get triple so in other words
we are going to get M minus 1 get triple
values triple values at this point so as
a result if you want to consider this as
a function
what does that function do the function
is a one-to-many function because given
one value of n it gives you many values
of triples because you know as you
iterate through you go from n as 1 to M
minus 1 so given one value of M you get
M minus 1 value of the triple hey that's
great that function I've highlighted
right now internally is a one-to-many
function but what I really want in the
outer loop is one list of all the
triples aha that's a one-to-many
function but I need to use the
one-to-many function to get a list of
values not on the stuff list of values
so that is kind of the thought process I
went through this to say first to
realize that these two are iterations
and second to realize that this one is a
one-to-many function and that just
clicked in my mind to say AHA that's a
one-to-many function which means that
the flatmap problem not a map problem as
long as you struggle with the map you're
gonna get stuck with it but realizing
it's a one-to-many function gives you
the relief so let's see how we're gonna
implement this using a flat map so what
I'm gonna do now is to go back to this
code and I'm going to bring in a few
different functions to work with the
first thing I'm gonna do here is I'm
gonna say stream dart let's say stream
dart eater rate and what am I going to
do with the iterate I'm gonna start with
the value of 2 because the collection is
starting with the value of 2 as you can
see so 2 comma given a value give me a
value plus 1 so this becomes an
iteration to go on and compute the
values just stare at this for a minute
what kind of iteration is it it's an
infinite stream it's an unbounded
collection of data
it starts with 2 & 2 & 3 & 4 & 5 & 6 7 8
and keeps on going there is absolutely
no limit to it I know what you're
thinking over there you're thinking my
goodness if it's really infinite where
would I store this on the cloud of
course but the point really is you take
the
Infinite's dream and now what are you
gonna do with it you're gonna then say a
flat map operation on it and that gives
you a value of M because you're
iterating over the outer collection so
this becomes an iteration right here a
flat map operation then what do we do
for every given value of n remember the
second iteration we go from n is 1 but
to 1 less than M well that's very easy
you simply say in here this becomes an
industry may range from the value to
pardon me 1 because we're starting with
the value of 1 but to value M minus 1 so
that basically becomes the M value right
here the range will go from 1 2 all the
way 1 less than the value you provide
right there then you perform a map
operation why do we perform a map
because notice this one for every value
of n you get a transformation of the get
triple so that becomes a map operation
we're given an n I call the get triple
of M comma N and that gives you the
value this itself is a collection but
then you take this collection a
one-to-many transformation and then you
flat map on it well once we do this a
little bit of a Java ism here so once we
do this the next step after this here
used to say dart limit and this is going
to be the number of values that I want
to limit
notice how beautifully you just have to
say it once to say give me that many
values no more than that you don't have
to say it twice and then of course once
you do this then you're going to simply
collect it to a list because all I want
to do here is return a list of values
and that comes from the collectors again
so that's basically the transformation
of the code so you start with the ETA
rate from 2 to M 2 to infinity and then
you say a flat map given all these
transformations for get tripled for M
and n I want to limit that to that many
values and return the result
out of it so when I run this code you
can see it produced the same result but
this was a little bit more intense
because we had to really figure out that
it's a one-to-many transformation and we
had to use a flat map in this case for
this kind of transformation so here the
flat map is a very powerful operation
one thing I want to leave you with this
key is to remember the one to one versus
the one to many and and that realization
has been fairly helpful for me in
figuring out when to use a map versus
when to use a flat map and that becomes
really helpful to use as well well so we
looked at this but we also used an
infinite stream to further that point
let's look one final example here to
wrap this up we're gonna start with the
code that's a little bit cryptic what
does this code really do let's take a
look at the code real quick notice it
says compute sum of square root of
primes
we have YZ Prime that's telling us if a
number is prime but notice I have a
start and I have a count now what does
this code really do it first of all sets
an index to start it sets a computer to
count to zero and a sum to be zero as
well then it says wild computer count is
less than count which is the value given
here then we check if the number is
prime if it is a prime number we find
the square root of it add to the sum and
then we increment the count right here
and then we also are incrementing the
index after that look at this code for a
minute and see this is an example of
accidental complexity the reason it's
accidental complexity is first of all
you have to initialize all these
variables then you had to check the
bounds over here now think about this
for a minute
computer count less than count what do
we do as programmers the minute you put
the less than symbol immediately you
come to a grinding halt and you ask the
question is it less than or less than or
equal to do you ever ask this question
every single time the new programmer
asked me once what is that
I said that's a international symbol for
confusion because every time you type it
you we look stupid isn't it you're like
huh you said less than or less than or
equal to we're never sure about it and
then of course you find the prime number
if it is a prime number you perform the
math then you have to increment it look
at the complexity this cannot be outside
these two cannot be inside this has to
be inside that has to be how cruel this
code is and the beauty is when you look
at this code it produces a result but
that's a lot of complexity built into it
like I mentioned earlier imperative code
is easier to write but really hard to
read you have to sit there and you
reason through the code that's a lot of
effort to do but how can we really make
this a lot simpler and much less effort
for us to work with so notice what I'm
gonna do now
I'm gonna go back to this code and say
why torture ourselves with all this
detail what I'm gonna do is return and
in this case I'm gonna say stream dot
eater rate we're gonna start with the
start value right here which is the
given value so we start comma given an
element element plus one so this says I
want to start iterating from the start
star plus want to start plus two and so
on then we say dot filter and in this
case all I'm gonna ask for is east prime
so start with an infinite series of
numbers starting with start but only
give me the prime numbers after that and
once you give me the prime number map
this over to in this case of course math
square root because all I care about the
square root of the values then you say
limit and I'm going to limit it to count
did you notice how that worked you pass
and ask the question is it count or does
it count minus one you don't have to
worry about it
it's count that's all you have to part
there's no confusion about it and then
you perform the sum operation again that
declarative style shines over there
you're not telling how to perform the
totaling you simply say called sum and
be done with it so you start with a
collection
of all the values starting with a with
start but you get all the prime numbers
starting with start but you get the
square root of prime numbers but you
only get the count of them and you
totally do get the results out of it and
then when you run the code of course it
produces the same result not only is the
code more concise it's a lot more easier
to understand it's a lot more fluent as
well as we can see here and that reduces
a burden on us quite a bit as you can
see right here so what does this code
really provide for us first of all the
code is very concise but I don't want
the code to be so concise it becomes
terse where it's really hard to
understand it's really important to make
the code easier to understand that's
where the conciseness matters the court
follows an infinite series and the
benefit of this is you can have any
number of elements I can create but
infinite series will not work without
lazy evaluations so laziness is one of
the most important virtues our
functional programming in fact if
somebody comes to you and says
object-oriented programming right what
would you say is really the core of
objective programming I would say
polymorphism right polymorphism is -
object-oriented programming because what
is the real benefit of optional
programming it is extensibility we get
from polymorphism so polymorphism is -
object of programming as I'm gonna say
lazy evaluation is - functional
programming because to me that is what
we really are after we want efficiency
through lazy evaluation so if you give
me a functional style but you don't give
me laziness it doesn't simply cut it
this is what I really enjoyed with
c-sharp for example when I looked at the
code I was first of all said oh my
goodness is this beautiful but the
performance is gonna suck isn't it and
then I discovered c-sharp can do
laziness automatically for you behind
the scenes and it doesn't do any extra
work this is what makes function
programming very approachable otherwise
languages like no for example
Ruby and JavaScript the Hat functional
style for a very long time but we cannot
use the functional style with big data
projects if we don't have the efficiency
in the code and and to really make this
affordable for intense computations in
Big Data we want efficiency and
performance so to me that laziness is
absolutely critical if you remove the
laziness of evaluation it is really what
you're getting is a cuteness of code not
the performance and efficiency so to me
the most important thing about a
functional style of programming really
is that laziness and and without
laziness there is really no point in
doing any of this because all you're
left with at the point is just cuteness
of code and you're not going to get
performance then there today and without
getting performance we're not going to
get go anywhere so to me that laziness
is extremely important that's what we
are seeing in this code is notice that
this is absolutely lazy it doesn't
evaluate this function until it really
requires that data so all these
functions are absolutely lazy they don't
perform any computations just to
illustrate the point right here let's go
back to this example real quick if I go
back over here and say output let's say
called right here and notice in this
example I'm gonna remove the return just
for a minute just return 0 for now but
let's go back to this code and run it
and notice it says called so many times
absolutely the code was actually called
just to make a little easier to see
let's change the value of 5 so we can
actually see that it called it that many
times on the other hand the whole thing
here I say that this is an example of
the fact that tail wags the dog right so
it's the tail that wags the dog this is
very useful because if you notice in
this example when I run this code it
performs all this work right here but
imagine for a minute think about the
scenario if you are at work on January
the second the balls boss calls you into
the office and says I've got a new
project for you you
work on it and the report is due on
April the 15th so what do you do on
January the second you come out from the
boss's office go to your desk and you
immediately start working on the new
project right no from the smile and some
of the people here I know that's not
true right
in fact why would you you will start on
it very promptly on April the 14th
because it's you on the 15th right
what is that call that's called being
smart isn't it in fact you know
something the boss doesn't know you know
you're gonna quit on March 1st why would
you bother starting this well that's
that's called efficiency so in this code
notice how it did the work right here
but I'm gonna simply comment out just
that call to sum that's all I did now
notice when I run this code it simply
gave the result but it never called that
method on line number 30 and all the
line number 31 for that matter and the
reason it never called the method on
line 30 and 31 is because it's
fundamentally lazy
it is these operations that trigger
these computations and if you don't have
the terminal operation you're not gonna
waste your time doing stuff that nobody
cares about
so without laziness there is no point in
really being functional and that's one
of the moments for me is that mainstream
languages not only just provided the
lambda expressions or the ability to use
higher-order functions because if that's
all they did I don't think we'll be here
talking about this today the fact that
the mainstream language has not only
provided higher-order functions but they
also went all the way to provide lazy
evaluations really embraces the full
power of functional programming and I
think that is the most charming part
with it hope that was useful thank you
[Applause]